oggi è il 26 febbraio 2014 e mercoledì
il governo ha giocato quattro giorni fa
ieri ha ottenuto la fiducia delle camere
io sto a roma su un divano in pigiama è
quasi ora di pranzo sono un po pigro sta
reggendo distrattamente il cellulare a
due metri da me sul tavolino primo sms
secondo sms mano poi rialzarmi però giro
di un minuto meno arrivano 45 allora
deve essere successo qualcosa mi alzo
leggo stefania giannini appena twittato
sono un nuovo capo di gabinetto non ha
idea di che cosa appena combinato il
problema è che non c'era nemmeno io la
mattina dopo va dal ministero per il mio
primo giorno di scuola
non faccio in tempo ad arrivare che sono
già sommerso di carte da vedere da
fermare di carte che si tramandano di
capo di gabinetto in capo di gabinetto
di cose che si sono sempre fatte così
che cosa trovo
anzitutto trovo la più grande burocrazia
italiana dicono che il ministero
dell'istruzione dell'università e della
ricerca sia il primo datore di lavoro in
europa abbiamo un milione 46.500 66
dipendenti e soprattutto trovo questo
trovo la più lunga
impressionante e sofisticata cinghia di
trasmissione del paese
otto milioni di studenti che ogni giorno
rispondono a 750 mila docenti che
rispondono a 8000 presidi che rispondono
al 93 capi degli uffici scolastici
provinciali che rispondono a 18 capi
degli uffici scolastici regionali che
rispondono a due capi dipartimento a cui
il capo di gabinetto fa un sacco di
domande sperando che rispondono ma non
sono questi i numeri che mi spaventano
lo spavento un'altra cosa mi spaventa
che per troppi anni ormai ci siamo
abituati a fare leggi ambigue incerte
che non sciolgono i nodi facciamo
emendamento i suoi emendamenti che hanno
costruito stratificazioni normative che
assomigliano un po le aree geologiche
per non parlare delle proroghe e delle
deroghe
per cui a un certo punto non si capisce
più quali siano le regole quali siano le
eccezioni e considerate che tutto questo
produce la burocrazia che cos'è la
burocrazia sono i funzionari che non
riescono a sciogliere i nodi che il
datore non ha voluto sciogliere non se
la prendono la responsabilità è anche
quando se la prendono anche quando
interpretano le leggi state certi che
c'è sempre qualcuno pronto ad andare
davanti ad un tari a dimostrare che
c'era anche un'altra interpretazione
possibile
ed ecco che tutto rallenta che niente
funziona e poi trovo una seconda cosa
trovo una caduta verticale
negli ultimi cinque anni fra il 2008 e
abbiamo perso il 10 per cento delle
risorse destinate alla scuola 46
miliardi di euro di tagli all'istruzione
ora quando arrivi in un posto così
e quando ci arrivi dopo un quinquennio
così hai solo due alternative la prima
per un atto di saggezza ti dice
lucidamente che non c'è niente da fare
che è meglio che cambi mestiere
la seconda e dirty follemente che non
c'è un posto più interessante in italia
oggi dove fare innovazione che una
burocrazia e l'intuizione è stata capire
che dobbiamo mettere insieme queste due
cose da un lato la necessità di fare le
leggi diversamente e dall'altra la
volontà di invertire questo trend di un
nuovo massiccio investimento nella
scuola la domanda allora però è come
siamo partiti alle persone abbiamo
approfittato di una riorganizzazione in
corso al ministero per promuovere alcuni
bravi dirigenti a posti di direttore
generale e da media meno di 40 anni
abbiamo colorato qualche pallino grigio
con il rosso e poi abbiamo messo al
timone ultima ancora più giovane che
aveva una specie di estra dose di
energia un team che era capace
letteralmente di notte quindi una volta
superata la giornata a correre dietro
l'emergenza sviluppare un pensiero lungo
attenzione questo pensiero lungo però
non l'abbiamo messo per chiuderci dentro
una stanza a cercare
di capire quale fosse il contenuto che
dovevamo tirare fuori lo abbiamo
utilizzato questo pensiero lungo per
dotarci di un metodo metodo con il quale
arrivare a distillare tutti i migliori
contenuti possibili
che cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo messo
insieme la memoria storica se volete del
ministero i saggi della scuola italiana
le persone più esperte di scuola che si
sono occupate di scuola negli ultimi 30
anni con un gruppo di persone che magari
sapevano un po meno di scuola ma
sapevano un pochino più di mondo moderno
di ciò che sta fuori della scuola e
questo mix ha prodotto in tre mesi un
rapporto che abbiamo chiamato la buona
scuola 140 pagine sottotitolo facciamo
crescere il paese
e a quel punto abbiamo chiesto al paese
che cosa ne pensasse abbiamo cercato di
avere meno filtri possibili non abbiamo
chiesto alle associazioni i sindacati
alle istituzioni
abbiamo chiesto direttamente ai
cittadini agli studenti e dalle famiglie
e docenti e presidi in due mesi è
diventata la più vasta e impressionante
e consultazione pubblica mai organizzata
da un governo europa abbiamo avuto 200
mila persone che hanno partecipato
online e altrettante che hanno
partecipato di persona in giro per
l'italia in oltre 2000 e dibattiti che
abbiamo organizzato che cosa è successo
di cosa ci siamo accorti di due cose
importanti
a forza di studiare quello che è di
approfondire quello che questa
consultazione ci stava restituendo è
venuto fuori che ovviamente in italia
c'era già un sacco di buona scuola
diffusa
c'erano molte buone prassi però noi non
potevamo limitarci a raccontarle o ad
applaudire perché noi siamo lo stato e
lo stato aveva la responsabilità aveva
il dovere di prendere tutte queste
strepitose eccezioni locali per
trasformarle in un'unica nuova regola
nazionale e quindi abbiamo scritto un
disegno di legge
lo abbiamo dato il parlamento abbiamo
chiesto al parlamento di fare in fretta
perché sarebbe iniziato nel settembre
successivo l'anno scolastico che a metà
luglio la buona scuola è diventata legge
dello stato
valore 3 miliardi
cosa c'è dentro questa buona scuola
anzitutto abbiamo deciso di rafforzare
la scuola con i docenti e quindi di dare
tanti docenti della scuola che mancavano
abbiamo cercato di vedere a questo
problema annoso per cui si fanno
supplenze dal primo di giorno di scuola
fino all'ultimo giorno di scuola a
decine di migliaia ogni anno quindi
abbiamo fatto in quattro mesi un piano
straordinario di assunzioni portando 83
mila nuovi docenti stabile dentro la
scuola italiana
tanto per darvi un'idea il ministero era
abituato ad assumere male e in ritardo
più o meno 20 mila persone
noi abbiamo assunto il quadruplo in
quattro mesi con una procedura mai fatta
prima nella storia d'italia nazionale
che ha permesso non solo di rimediare a
queste graduatorie storiche di
cominciare a smaltire queste questo
precariato strutturale che avevamo ma
anche di mettere insieme diritto
amministrativo aspettative decennali e
anche un po di alta matematica e poi
siamo che c'è adesso come andiamo avanti
facciamo una cosa più strepitosa che si
possa fare in un paese come l'italia
cioè torniamo alla normalità ne parlavo
prima di deroghe per ora che sapete
quanti concorsi pubblici ci sono stati
per entrare a scuola negli ultimi 25
anni
3 90 99 2012 quindi adesso bandiamo un
concorso per 63 mila posti questo numero
che vedete non sono i candidati sono i
posti 63.000 posti con cui torniamo alla
costituzione
ovviamente non ci interessa solo la
quantità dei docenti ma ci interessa
anche la qualità della formazione e
quindi della conoscenze che questi
docenti riescono a trasmettere ragazzi
quindi abbiamo deciso di investire 40
milioni di euro all'anno sulla
formazione dei docenti sono tanti sono
pochi vita un dato per confrontarlo fino
a poco tempo fa i milioni erano quattro
siamo passati a 40 abbiamo aggiunto 10
non abbiamo deciso di incrementare le
risorse abbiamo deciso di cambiare
ordine di grandezza non abbiamo più
tempo
le cose piccole la formazione servirà
perché vogliamo scommettere sulla
disponibilità dei docenti italiani di
rimettersi in gioco e quindi vogliamo
offrire ogni docente che si rimette in
gioco la possibilità di avere
un'occasione di miglioramento personale
e anche per questo diamo 500 euro
docente per fare auto formazione per
andare al teatro per comprare un libro
per fare un corso di aggiornamento che
hanno detto chissà come li spenderanno
la risposta è stata che ovviamente un
ministero mette in piedi un sistema di
monitoraggio di rendicontazione
la risposta avere che lo stato torna a
fidarsi dei propri cittadini e questa
fiducia alla base anche di un altro
concetto fondamentale della buona scuola
che l'autonomia
noi stiamo rendendo le scuole è molto
più autonomi e guardate che per quel
ministero per quella cinghia di
trasmissione che ho detto prima non è
proprio un esercizio banale smontare un
meccanismo che andate avanti per decenni
più autonomia significa più valutazione
perché di mezzo c'è la parola
responsabilità e quindi qui facciamo
valutazione delle scuole e rafforziamo
il sistema nazionale di valutazione
delle scuole ma anche valutazioni dei
presidi e docenti non è la costruzione
di classifiche e graduatorie quando
diciamo valutazione delle scuole
significa dare ad ogni scuola una
fotografia dei propri punti di forza dei
propri punti di debolezza perché lo
scopo incoraggiare ogni scuola a darsi
un percorso una strategia grazie a
quella autonomia per cui diventano un
migliore della scuola destra o sinistra
ma diventa migliore di se stesso della
scuola che è stato fino a un anno e un
mese una settimana fa
poi abbiamo messo a 100 milioni di euro
all'anno sull'alternanza scuola lavoro e
l'abbiamo reso obbligatoria 400 ore
negli istituti tecnici e professionali e
200 ore nei licei
anche qui per darvi un riferimento sono
poche risorse sono tanti e le risorse
fino ad oggi che c'erano erano 10
milioni
abbiamo aggiunto un'altra volta allo
zero lo stesso ragionamento cambiamo
ordine di grandezza perché l'abbiamo
fatta obbligatoria anzitutto perché è
importante che i ragazzi imparino saper
fare e poi perché ci siamo anche detti
spassionatamente la esistono cose
importanti che sono facoltative e alla
fine un piano per la scuola digitale in
italia
qui abbiamo capito che lo scopo non era
studiare l'ultimo device da portare in
classe lo scopo non è portare il
digitale a scuola lo scopo è portare la
scuola
nell'era digitale complessa cominciamo a
pagare il canone di connettività le
scuole perché nel 2015
internet è altrettanto importante della
carta igienica mille docenti e presidi
avranno la possibilità di andare
all'estero per fare un corso di alta
formazione digitale
stiamo ridendo progressivamente il
coating in tutte le scuole elementari di
italia facciamo degli hack aton
costruiamo delle aule aumentati e
laboratori territoriali
immaginate 35 misure così da qualche mi
lamenti che valgono un miliardo
ora non tutto è andato come ci eravamo
immaginati
ogni volta che abbiamo fatto delle
scelte
c'è stato qualcuno che ha protestato
perché consiglio di non essere stato
dato abbiamo anche fatto degli errori
però abbiamo imparato una cosa
importante abbiamo imparato che per
avere un investimento di 3 miliardi a
favore di un ministero non basta buona
tecnica serve molta democrazia
abbiamo imparato che un investimento di
3 miliardi lo ottieni non facendo un
blitz dell'ultima ora in consiglio dei
ministri ma capendo che lo scopo è
smettere di ragionare in termini di
scrivere una legge e di cominciare a
ragionare in termini di disegnare una lo
tieni sostanzialmente se accetti di
correre un rischio e nella pubblica
amministrazione è raro accettare di
correre un rischio negli ultimi 20 anni
che ha fatto le leggi ho sempre pensato
che il segreto fosse tenere nascoste le
informazioni
noi abbiamo fatto l'opposto abbiamo
dichiarato da subito pubblicamente tutte
le nostre intenzioni e nel dettaglio
abbiamo candidamente confessato quello
che volevamo fare e lo sapevamo che ci
sarebbe stato qualcuno pronto a prendere
una frase di tre righe da un rapporto di
140 pagine per organizzarci sopra uno
sciopero generale
e abbiamo deciso di perdere il controllo
altra cosa rara nella pubblica
amministrazione perché abbiamo deciso
abbiamo accettato di perdere il
controllo perché l'unica maniera per
portare fino in fondo tutto questo era
perdere il controllo noi perché se non
potevamo per fermare questo processo
nessuno da fuori ci avrebbe potuto
obbligare a farlo
esattamente vent'anni fa di questi
giorni stavo sempre su un divano e
sempre in pigiama e provavo a capire che
cosa fare da grande e mi facevo la
domanda che a 17 anni si fanno un po
tutti ma mi scriva all'università che mi
piace o mi iscrivo all'università che mi
dà lavoro
alla fine ho fatto l'università che è
capitata però con gli anni una cosa l'ho
capita e che ovviamente non c'è
l'università che automaticamente di da
lavoro e ho capito anche che i mestieri
più interessanti sono quelli che quando
ti scrive l'università non esistono
ancora
quindi quando oggi ragazzi mi chiedono
un consiglio io lo so cosa rispondere
fate l'università che vi piace però
continuano a guardarmi perplessi
e allora migliore il dubbio che ci sia
un'altra domanda che ronza loro dentro
la testa ancora ma tu a 17 anni lo sai
cosa ti piace la buona scuola e il
tentativo pubblico e collettivo di dare
una risposta a questa domanda
estremamente intima e personale è il
modo con cui abbiamo deciso di aiutare
ogni ragazzo a misurare il mondo e prima
del mondo a misurare se stesso non
alzandosi dopo il divano per andare
davanti allo specchio alzandosi da quel
divano per fare tante esperienze diverse
fino a capire che talento a cosa lo
smuove come sporcarsi le mani
a che cosa non è disposto a rinunciare
fino a capire non cosa vuole fare
ma chi può essere
grazie